VINAY BALASUBRAMANIAM: Good
morning, good afternoon,
good evening, and thanks
for joining the session
on Inside BigQuery BI Engine.
I'm Vinay Balasubramaniam.
I'm a product
manager on BigQuery.
I'm joined by Mosha
Pasumansky, who
is a principal
engineer on BigQuery.
So in today's session,
we will talk about,
give an overview
of what BigQuery BI
Engine is, why we built it, what
is the core value proposition.
We talk about, next we go into
the internals of BI engine,
and we spend a the rest
of most of the talk
in talking about
how BI Engine works.
In the end we'll have some
exciting demos to showcase
how BI Engine handles
higher concurrency.
And then we'll have
Madeleine from Tableau
showcasing a demo of
BI Engine with Tableau,
and we'll have Kevin
from Looker talk
about how BI Engine
works with Looker.
So let's get started.
Doing BI on big data is quite
challenging for customers, too.
So customers today have to
manage multiple data marts
around the data
warehouse, extract data,
manage complex ETL pipeline
to make the BI tools.
And that creates additional
management overhead
and administration [? hold. ?]
Secondly, today
traditional BI applications
are used to extracting data
from the data warehouse,
creating OLAP cubes, running
[? IT ?] jobs to refresh those
cubes.
So they end up looking
at the dashboard, which
is on all data.
More and more
customers are looking
for not only fast and
interactive dashboard,
but also they're looking
at more real time data
so that they can get insights
faster and take action
accordingly.
And lastly organization,
as they scale globally,
they want to share their
information and insights
not only to internal
stakeholders,
but also to external
partners and customers.
So this adds a lot of additional
concurrency requirements
for their BI solutions.
These are some of
the reasons why we
wanted to build the BI Engine.
If we look at GCP Smart
Analytics platform,
we provide solutions across
all the different life cycles
of BI, starting from connecting
to multiple data sources,
whether it's on prem
sources or software
as a service end points.
We can bring in data from
multiple sources into BigQuery.
And as part of
that transformation
we provide tools such
as Cloud Dataflow
to do transformation and
enrichment on your streaming
data.
You have Cloud Data Fusion,
which looks at traditional ETL
style transformation.
Then we have Dataproc for Spark
and Hadoop sort of workflow.
Once the data is in BigQuery,
you can create a metadata layer
to discover data
through data catalog,
you can use Cloud Dataprep
for data wrangling,
and then you can connect
the data from BigQuery
to multiple BI tools.
We provide first party BI
solutions, Looker, Data Studio,
and Sheets.
We also have connectors from our
rich ecosystem of BI partners,
including Tableau Power
BI, MicroStrategy and Click
[INAUDIBLE].
But where BI Engine
is really helpful
is it acts as an acceleration
layer between BigQuery
and your BI tool.
So all, not just Data Studio,
other BI tools can use this.
So the overall vision
for BigQuery BI Engine
is to democratize BI,
enabling business analysts
to perform interactive
analytics in real time.
So today BI tools compromise
between data freshness
and speed.
So if you want data to be
really fast and interactive,
it's not fresh.
But if you want data to
be fresh and latest data
without any staleness,
it's not fast.
With BigQuery BI
engine, we don't
want to compromise between
freshness and speed.
We always want to
give you fresh data
and also it always
has to be fast.
Now, three key value
propositions of BigQuery BI
Engine.
It provides sub-second queries,
it simplifies the architecture,
and it has smart tuning
built. Let's go into each one.
To achieve sub-second
queries, BI Engine
is a column-oriented
in-memory execution engine.
It can scale horizontally so as
you have more requests coming
in, the engine can load
balance that request
by making copies of
data in memory and load
balance those requests.
And lastly BI Engine works
with BigQuery streaming.
So as you're streaming data
in, the data is automatically
refreshed into the
in-memory queue
so you get the latest data.
In terms of simplification
of architecture,
BI engine is built on
top of BigQuery storage.
So there's no need to
extract data out of BigQuery.
We automatically move
data between the storage
tier and the memory tier.
And traditional
BI tools required
you to create OLAP cubes, but we
do that automatically for you.
That reduces complexity
in architecture.
And lastly, today, BI engine
is available to Data Studio,
but what we're
bringing to market
is BI Engine SQL API, which is
integrated with BigQuery API
directly.
So any of the other BI tools,
including Looker, Tableau,
Power BI, Click,
MicroStrategy, et cetera,
can leverage that
without having to make
any change on their side.
And lastly, there are smart
tuning built into BI Engine.
So BI Engine has inbuilt
cache optimizations,
which we do automatically
based on your data.
And the way you do that is
you create a reservation
where you specify the location
you want the reservation to be,
specify the size, and
automatically BI Engine
takes care of tuning the data
based on your query patterns.
And all of this data, which
is available to Stackdriver,
so you can look at how
much cache is being used,
how much memory is being
used, how much of that
is coming from cache, how much
it's falling back to BigQuery.
All of this rich
information and metrics
is available at BI engine.
Well, that was a quick
overview of BI engine.
Now let's go into how BI
Engine works in the internals.
Let me introduce Mosha to
you to walk us through that.
MOSHA PASUMANSKY:
Thank you Vinay.
My name is Mosha
Pasumansky, and I'm
very excited to talk today with
you about the inner workings
of BigQuery BI Engine.
So we start with the high
level architecture of BigQuery.
And we see three
main pieces here.
On the left is storage.
That's where BigQuery
stores all of its data.
On the right, compute.
That's where query
processing is happening.
And between them shuffle
layer, which facilitates
distributed processing.
Now let's see where BI Engine
fits into this picture.
We see BI Engine is just
another feature of BigQuery.
It's not a separate product.
So it works on top of the
same storage, same network,
same shuffle layer,
and it [? worker ?]
run alongside of
BigQuery workers.
OK, well if it's exactly
same architecture, what
makes it possible
for BI Engine to get
such dramatic
performance improvements?
And this is exactly what
we're going to talk about now.
So we see there are
three big pieces.
And all three of them
contribute to the performance
of the query.
Storage is a disk I/O time,
shuffle is a network I/O time,
and compute is CPU.
So what we're going
to do now, we'll
pick each one of
those three components
and talk how BI Engine
makes this time go to zero.
OK, let's start
with the disk I/O.
And this one may seem
to be the most obvious,
because we just
put data in memory
and there is no disk
I/O. And of course, it
would have been that simple
if we had unlimited memory
and we can put all
the data into it.
But of course it's
more complex than that.
We'll have to manage and figure
out what to keep in memory
and what to leave on disk.
And that's where
the BI Engine memory
manager comes into the picture.
This is really the
most important piece.
It's the heart of the BI Engine.
So let's see how it works.
First of all, BigQuery is
a column-based database,
so we only put specific
columns into memory, not
the whole table.
But more than that, we're not
putting the entire column;
we're only putting chunks of it.
And that works equally well
with both partition tables
and not partition tables.
So even if your table is
not partitioned from time
and it keeps data going
multiple years back,
but you're only
querying last few days,
memory manager
will figure it out.
Next, memory manager not
only keeps the raw data,
it also keeps
direct calculations,
like intermediate results
of aggregations and so on.
Also we talked about
how BI Engine is always
fast and always fresh.
So to be always fresh and
not to serve stale data,
it has very tight integration
with metadata service.
It knows exactly when
transactions commit.
It keeps exactly the
same snapshot timestamps
as the rest of BigQuery, so
whenever new data comes in,
it knows how to
pick it up and mesh
with existing data in memory.
Even when data changes
through [INAUDIBLE] memory
manager knows exactly
which parts of it
should be invalidated
and which should not.
Also memory manager knows how
to work with load balancing.
Even if you have small
table, but with a lot
of querying coming
in, it may choose
to implicate same data over
multiple machines, which
is easy for us to
do because BigQuery
is distributed database.
So this way it will use small
memory, but all of the queries
will still have very
fast response time
because the load will be spread.
So you can see, it's a
pretty sophisticated system.
Now let's see what kind of
control users have over it.
And this control comes in
form of BI reservations.
BI reservations are very
similar to classic BigQuery
reservations, but the
currency is memory.
So you are buying memory
and not slots or CPU.
All the metrics we serve
through Stackdriver,
so the users can understand
how efficiently they're
using the system.
For example, in this
picture you see two lines.
Blue one is how much
reservation user bought,
and the orange one is
how much there was used.
So user can save,
they bought too much
and there is too
much unused, they
can lower the reservation
size and it takes effect
immediately.
And when they see that the
orange start bumping into blue,
meaning that the
reservation is not
enough for the
current workload, user
may choose to buy a little
bit more reservation
and balance it like that.
OK, so we covered how we
deal with storage component.
Now let's talk about
compute or CPU.
There are many, many techniques
that we use to improve CPU.
I'll talk about
a couple of them.
First one is
vectorized processing.
So what you see on the left is
the classic way how databases
deal, their query engine dealt
with query processing, which
is called sometimes
[INAUDIBLE] iterator or tuple
iterator model.
Basically it says,
query plan comes
as a [? trio ?] of iterators,
and those iterators
consume one row at a time.
Process it, send to
the next iterator,
takes next row, and so on.
So this is very general and
very well understood model,
but it's not the best
one, especially when we're
dealing with column-based
data structure
and within memory databases.
So in recent year another model
called vectorized processing
became more popular.
Here instead of
adding the whole row
and sending it to the
[? trio ?] of operators,
we pick single column at a
time, read like 1,000 values,
process them in tight loop,
and then send forward.
So this is much
more complex model,
but you don't need
to worry about it
because we took care of it.
We wrote the entire
runtime in BigQuery
to use vectorized separators,
and we put this new runtime
into BI Engine.
So there are a lot of
benefits for CPU for it.
First, the cache
locality is much better
because you run very,
very localized loops.
And second, your code
doesn't jump around between
[? operator ?] to
[? operator, ?] so we can fill
the CPU pipeline much tighter.
We also take advantage
of modern CPU instruction
called SMG
instructions which can
process many values at the
same clock cycle and so on.
So we've got great
benefits from it.
Another technique
that we're using
is we're using many
different encodings.
So we already have support for
a few encodings in our storage
system.
But now that the
data is in memory,
we have the liberty of
using many, many more,
because it's much
easier to change them
in a memory representation.
I will touch couple
of them here.
First one is the most well-known
one, is a dictionary encoding.
It works really well then you
have a table with millions
of rows but certain column has
only a few distinct values,
like maybe 100 or in
this picture only three.
And the column is
the name of the song.
So when you have
complex expression,
instead of computing
it again and again
over each one of
those million values,
you just compute it
over the dictionary
and keep the result. In this
case, the result is [INAUDIBLE]
but it can [INAUDIBLE].
Now this is, by the
way, an example of one
of the derived calculations
that I talked earlier when
we talked about memory manager.
So the benefit is huge.
Instead of doing computation
millions of times,
we'll do it only three times.
Dictionary encoding can be
used in many other operators,
in aggregations, in joins,
in analytic functions.
So it's a great technique.
Another technique is
run length encoding.
So you can see example
on the right here.
It works really
well when you have
same value in the column
repeated many times in a row.
So here we have
example with quarters.
And we have quarter
one three times
and quarter two four times.
So again, instead of
computing the same expression
three times, we'll compute
it once and just say oh,
and please give this
result three times.
Now we'll have dozens
of different encodings,
and they can stack one
on top of the other
like you can use both
dictionary [INAUDIBLE]
for example and many others.
So again, BI Engine takes
care of it all automatically.
It looks at the data, its
statistics and query history,
and figures out which encoding
is going to be the best.
So this is how we deal
with CPU, now let's go
and talk how we
deal with network.
How can we eliminate
network or reduce it?
So the way we approach it
is from the query planner
perspective.
Basically we look at the query
plans that BigQuery generates
and most of those plans
are distributed plans.
And then we say, OK
how we can improve it,
given that we have
this BI Engine
with its stateful workers
and different scheduling
policy and the memory data.
So let's again pick
a couple of examples.
What you can see here is a
very simple aggregation query.
And the distributed plan
in the classic BigQuery
will be two stages.
First stage will
do some filtering
and then do
preliminary aggregation
and will compute
intermediate results.
Then we'll send them
all over the network
to compute the final result. OK?
With BI Engine, here's
the plan with BI Engine.
So it's funny because it
looks almost exactly the same,
but now instead of
doing distributed plan,
we're running parallel plan.
Basically our scheduler knows
where each piece of data
resides on each worker,
can bundle them together
and say, run the same plan but
this time not over the network.
Run it as a parallel plan, OK?
Do this local aggregation
locally, and then also
measure the result also locally.
And now only after
that you can send it
to the distributed execution.
So network traffic
is reduced greatly.
Let's look into another little
bit more complex example.
So here, we're
talking about joins.
And there are many
join plans in BigQuery
but one pretty popular one
is called Broadcast Join.
It works very well when
you have a big table,
let's say a fact table,
joining with a smaller
one like dimension table.
So a typical plan
in BigQuery would
be to take this small table
and broadcast into all workers,
and broadcast goes
over the network.
Now what we can
do with BI Engine,
our memory manager can
look into it and say,
you know what, this small
table is small enough.
Why don't I just
replicate it across all
of the nodes which have the
pieces of the fact table.
So it will use a
little bit more memory.
But now, join can happen
completely locally.
We don't need to
use network at all.
OK, so this kind of
decision memory manager
can do because it knows
the reservation size,
it knows the query
workload, so it can do
this kind of automatic tuning.
OK so now we covered all three
big components of BigQuery
architecture and
talked a little bit how
we improve each one of them.
And it's time to see
how it actually works.
We're going to show
you three demos.
We're starting
with the first one
to demonstrate how BI Engine
handles high concurrency.
And this is artificial
demo which we simulated,
and it simulates the
following situation.
Let's say you have
a company and you
have table which is
multi-million rows table
in this example, in this demo.
And we'll have many business
users and analysts which
need to work with this data.
So let's say they all
have complex dashboards.
And dashboards have many,
many visual elements.
So we simulated single dashboard
sends 10 different queries, OK?
And also said, you
know, dashboards
are not static reports.
People work with them.
So we said, you know, what
if each one of those users
changes dashboard
once every second.
And we say, you know
this is very unrealistic,
nobody will change
it every second.
But we'll say, let's push it.
OK, so many users with
dashboards, each dashboard
sends 10 queries every second.
So what we're looking
here is Stackdriver,
which captures few metrics.
First metric we are
going to focus on
is this blue line, which shows
the throughput measured in QPS.
And we can see that we're
starting with 100 QPS, which
roughly represents
10 users sends
10 queries each every second.
All those queries are
completely randomly generated.
They're not the same.
You know there is nobody
using same query result.
It's totally BI Engine
working full speed.
100 queries a second.
Actually 100 is too small.
Let's increase it to 1,000.
OK?
OK, you see, we're
working with 1,000.
Now it's like 100 users
working with those dashboards.
Let's ramp it up.
You know, how high?
OK 2,000.
200 users every
second, 10 queries.
System is working.
But now how well is it working?
Maybe it's falling apart.
So to see how those
systems scale,
we would need to look into
different metric, which
is query response metrics.
And you know you see
those three lines
at the bottom of the chart?
It's kind of hard to see because
they're kind of very low, so
let's zoom in onto them, OK?
So those three lines
represent the percentiles
of query response.
The lowest one, which
I think is orange,
shows the 50th percentile,
which is medium.
OK?
And then the next one is red.
It shows 95th percentile,
because it's also
very important to look at
latency in the large scale
systems.
And finally the blue, the violet
one is the 99th percentile.
So first thing that we
observe is no matter
how far we ramp
up our query load,
they stand largely
horizontal, largely the same.
Might be at 2,000 QPS they
increase, but only a tiny bit.
Also absolute times
are really good.
Like 50th percentile is
only 35 milliseconds.
95th percentile is lower
than 100 milliseconds.
And 99th percentile
is 150 milliseconds.
Remember this is many,
many million rows table
and we're running at 2,000 QPS.
2,000 queries every second.
So I can see that BI
Engine holds really well.
So that was throughput demo,
and I'm passing it over to Vinay
to show two other demos.
VINAY BALASUBRAMANIAM:
Thank you, Mosha.
And you saw how BI Engine is
able to scale much more higher
to provide higher concurrency.
Now I want to introduce
Madeleine Corneli, who's
a product manager at
Tableau, to showcase
an initial preview of how
Tableau and BigQuery BI
Engine works together.
MADELEINE CORNELI:
We're going to start off
in Tableau Desktop.
And the first thing
I'm going to do
is I'm going to connect to
my Google BigQuery instance.
Then I can choose what data
I want to analyze today.
To leverage BI Engine,
all I need to do
is ensure I connect
to the billing project
where BI Engine is enabled.
Then I can select the
project and dataset
where my data lives.
I'll then pull out
the table or tables
that I want to analyze today.
Hopping into our first
sheet, I can pull out
the number of records
field to quickly see
that we're working with
a dataset of over 87
million rows.
That's a pretty hefty
dataset to work with.
Now this data contains
lots of customer reviews
of various health and
beauty products sold
by a company called YLM.
I can use Tableau to quickly
aggregate the overall reviews
for all of these products.
Looking at the average review,
I can see what of our products
have scored very high and which
ones haven't scored as high.
Tableau also makes it
easy to quickly switch
between various
visualization types.
Let's call this Product Reviews.
Now, each of these
products lives
in various different categories.
Tableau makes it very
easy for me to group
these various categories
together into something
we call a hierarchy.
I'm going to create a new
hierarchy called Product.
And by doing so,
it makes it easy
for me to drill up and
down between various levels
of granularity in my data.
Now for this view,
I'd like to get
a sense of the overall
quantity of sales I have
for each one of my categories.
I'd also like to add the context
of the average rating, as well.
Now every time I use
aggregate rating here,
I'm typically going to want to
look at the average overall.
So I'm going to set the default
property to use average.
I also want to change the
color scheme, as well.
I want to make sure that I don't
miss any of these products that
may have lower reviews as
I go through my analysis.
Now I can see that there are
certain product categories
where I have a high
quantity of sales
but the aggregate
rating isn't very high.
And that might be something
I want to investigate.
Let's call this Product
Reviews and Quantity.
I'd also like to look at
this data geographically.
This dataset already
includes state information,
so I can simply drag
state out onto the view,
and Tableau will
plot that for me.
Now I can also add
quantity, as well.
So we can see which states
have higher quantities sold.
I'm going to add aggregate
rating to the view again.
And I can see that
generally the states
where I have higher
numbers of sales,
I also typically have
better product ratings.
However there are
some problem areas
that I may want to investigate.
I can easily drill down
to a lower level of detail
to figure out if there are
specific cities where I have
high quantity but low ratings.
Let's bump up the size a little
bit so it's easier to see.
We'll call this Product
Ratings and Quantity by City.
Finally, I want to pull together
all of these visualizations
onto something we call
a Tableau dashboard.
Using a dashboard makes
it easy to compare
multiple visualizations
at the same time.
It also gives me the
ability to add interactivity
between these
various worksheets.
Doing so effectively creates
an interactive application
that lets me visually
explore my data.
I can look at some of
our problem subcategories
and select a particular region
to explore in more detail.
And finally, I can
pinpoint exact products
that have low reviews.
And so with that, in
just a few minutes,
we've built an
interactive dashboard
on top of over 87 million rows
of data thanks to BI Engine.
Now I can publish this to
Tableau Server or Tableau
Online and share it
with other people
throughout my organization.
VINAY BALASUBRAMANIAM:
Thanks Madeleine.
That was a great demo
of how Tableau and BI
Engine can work together.
Now, I want to introduce
Kevin Marr who's
a product manager in Looker to
talk about how Looker and BI
Engine work together.
KEVIN MARR: Hi.
I'm Kevin, a product
manager at Looker,
and I'll be showing you Looker's
integration with BigQuery's BI
Engine.
First, Looker is a modern
data analytics platform
that operates in database.
This means that Looker does
not ingest your source data.
If you load a report or
visualization in Looker,
a SQL query is
being sent directly
to your data warehouse.
And as you can imagine,
having a very fast data
warehouse means that
you'll get a very
good experience in Looker.
So I'm in Looker's
Explore page, which
allows business
users to self-serve
by exploring their
data, building
their own visualizations,
and ultimately answering
their own questions.
The Explore page is powered
by Looker's modeling layer
called LookML, which
provides an abstraction
layer between your database
schema and the business terms
that your users
are familiar with.
All I have to do
to build a query
here is select dimensions
and measures and add filters.
Say I want to know the
total revenue we've ever
made in our fictitious
e-commerce store.
I can just click on the Total
Sales measure and hit Run.
Behind the scenes,
Looker has generated
a query, a SQL query for me,
and has sent that to BigQuery,
in this case, BI Engine,
and has given me the answer,
in this case, $9.6 million.
It's easy for me to add
things like filters.
Say that I want to look at
this over some constrained
timeframe.
I can click on a filter.
I can pick any of these easy
point-and-click options.
I'll just pick, say, April 2020.
So starting on the 1st of April
and ending on the 1st of May.
As I've done those interactions
with the user interface,
again, Looker is adapting the
SQL to reflect what I want.
So when I hit Run, that SQL gets
sent to BigQuery's BI Engine
and the result is posted here.
Great.
So in April 2020 my
business made $441,000.
Also if I jump over to
the BigQuery console,
we can take a look
at those queries,
and you just get a sense for how
fast these queries really are.
I click on this, you can see
that that query I just ran
took only a quarter of a second.
Now let's take a step
further and maybe I
want to create a visualization.
Maybe I want to
create a time series.
I can do that just by adding
the date dimension to my query.
Again, hitting Run.
Looker adapted the SQL.
And the result is displayed
here in Looker's user interface.
I want to visualize
it, I can just
open up the Visualization
section, where
we have a myriad of viz types.
In this case Looker
things that a line chart
is the best [? base of ?]
my data, which I like.
And I'll go ahead and
save this to a dashboard.
I have a nice little
test dashboard I added.
I'll save it there.
And I'll pop that
open in my other tab.
I'll go ahead and refresh
this dashboard just
to rerun these queries again.
We've turned off all
caching on this demo,
just to show off the
query speed in BI Engine.
The dashboard's done
rendering already.
And at the bottom I
can see my new tile.
I actually added two from
a previous recording,
but pretend it's just one.
Dashboards in Looker
are also designed
to be heavily interactive.
So say that right
now we're looking
at just the data over Facebook,
I can deselect that selection
and that'll cross-filter
across all my other queries.
And I can see the data
broadly across all
the demographic profiles.
I can also adjust filters
directly in the top.
Say I want to look at this
specifically in some city, say,
San Francisco, where I live.
I can start typing
that in, and Looker
will start offering suggestions
based on my underlying data.
So I can click that,
rerun the dashboard,
and see how this is trending
just in San Francisco.
Great.
That's it.
Thank you very much.
VINAY BALASUBRAMANIAM:
Thanks, Kevin.
So in conclusion, BI
Engine is available today.
You can try it today
with Data Studio.
It's a GA product.
It's available today.
But what we're really
showcasing here
is how BI Engine SQL API
makes it possible to work,
to give the same acceleration,
same benefits with other BI
tools, including
Looker, Tableau,
and other BI tools who work
with the query directly.
So that's coming.
Sometime end of this year
we'll have a initial preview.
And also there are
additional session
to learn more about, if you
want to know about how BigQuery
is evolving in other areas,
there's a session DA 200,
which talks about
BigQuery's roadmap.
And if you want to learn
about how Looker is evolving
and their roadmap,
there's a session, DA 239.
So do watch out, and
again, thanks for joining.